don't read my name
it's paradise and welcome to [ __ ] we're
gonna go here I don't know how the hell
I missed that I was in this room
I don't know how Friday long like banana
long I don't know why I use that word
I'm sorry if I offended anyone that's
right I get scared when I come near all
right so we're gonna go to third floor
it's gonna be enemies
not gonna lie I get to fit hey what is
it fun lady like you doing here
construction area not gonna stop me you
can't stop me
what is this nope can't go in there
well oh we can go in here no baby not
Justin Bieber's fun [ __ ] up that's right
Justin so ugly so ugly I don't even know
I got an SMG though Oh batteries I take
them I take them I took to my tagged him
by then I do [ __ ] I hate them fun [ __ ]
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] this
I speak tough days [ __ ] way be
back now man Jima spot man Dimas party
[ __ ] my foot
okay back let's stop the [ __ ] up blah
blah ah so annoying
I got a do all I think ah where am I no
bueno kids I know
well little [ __ ] hey all again ladies
and gentlemen stop sucking your dick
well you know that's that's just a
lesson in life you live in your line you
you are not in the mood right now not in
the [ __ ] mood now so annoying
seriously this interface sucks major
dick if I plus two it doesn't do
anything because one it chase to fit
there but two doesn't changed anything
three doesn't do anything for changes I
don't understand it well I speak
Japanese [ __ ] I'm gonna start
using quick sake jump jump duck duck
Duck Duck Duck Duck
come on baby the [ __ ] are you you [ __ ]
hell is you know you oh come come at me
rah come at me brow you [ __ ] spiders
tchoff-tchoff-tchoffo-tchoffo-tchoff
get the [ __ ] out of my face [ __ ] yeah
yeah [ __ ] I know my fake [ __ ] I jump
you get your penis Chuck so dumb that's
how I roll that's how I [ __ ] another
fine lady sorry okay so what broke that
bed hmm I was here was a net
yeah yeah while along what is this this
is the archives but a monthly plan the
plan this month is to renovate the third
floor fixing the wiring in the rooms
with heavy machinery
Gogi also lake they blocked it I get it
let's check it damn it construction oh
my god what a nice way to say there's a
lot of time grey if you just realize
that just pointed it out they're just
doing it for you
all right stop playing with a nap can I
go here nah we got to take the highway
to here oh god job [ __ ] chop the rail
now stop playing with the night and your
mom I ever tell you to stop dating with
the night okay I have a little bandages
now look I don't always have little help
heads good let's go see you later
construction area [ __ ] up my life I
think it's in here
alright here goes nothing chop snake
whoa
I'm just gonna jump down I don't even
get into Falcom information I found
though illuminating was unexpected
mother led me to the hospital where
father had once been kept prisoner Bava
body and mind his manners as they call
it meant he could never live a normal
life again the a Salem Hospital looked
down at me with menacing eyes
lad and I Arab desperation about it a
shared history of hundreds lasso swords
and could in card a little Here I am
baby
sassy deliverer cha-cha-cha
didn't work they don't work I thought
the lurch was something like that no no
no no bad bad zombie bad zombie shut up
so annoying shup stop you can't lick my
toes I won't let you lick on stop stop
do you even have a tongue I can do that
too Wow
that's right baby girl give me a kiss
that's right that's right
don't give me kids I don't even care
what do we got no no no no what what
what [ __ ] Oh captain beaver spawns okay
what again chop chop chop
okay chop chop chop the top I think so
no I didn't what is this another padlock
I think I know the code actually but I
don't remember in my head whoa look at
that
skills nah check out the other doors
allow finals uh door control okay I got
this uh all right let's go with that
that works
what about the ah kin period mattresses
seriously go be a mattress somewhere
else
good what are you even doing here stop
being so annoying okay I don't like stop
door oh come on I hate those little
[ __ ] [ __ ] I hate them
oh yeah Harold but Carl oh that's what
it is but Carl that's fine no wonder
that won't close this area off yeah it's
full of boxes you're right ray yeah I
multi-character Zenyatta
Hebrews told me there will be stuff in
these do you like to me I feel sad I
feel really sad hello
Black Ducks gotta lotta stop blaming
that very mud in the chair what are you
doing what are you doing what are you
doing what how did you do it that's how
I roll that's how I get all the ladies
it's locked
I can't have open it somewhere else well
what about the door control doesn't that
work did it it does not work and
what about in here lady this very came
from I think we have a problem that's
log
what did by is multicom face
what's the nice thing here I swear to
God there was thing here
okay now I'm kind of creeped that well
[ __ ] it I'm probably screwed anyway okay
what did we go why did we go
does he have a scissor in his balls I
Sisson night
don't worry okay I have to find another
way maybe the door control will do
something I don't know oh come in come
in come in come in come in klappa klappa
klappa klappa what the TV's turning off
there we go oh yeah it's nothing in
their outdoor don't [ __ ] with me well
that means there's got to be something
here what it what what in the hell okay
can you stay there or something what
about this
but it isn't not nothing works
uh oh I get it yeah uh fifty-fifty
but lack of ass
please tell me I did it like about like
about like a bathroom too bad you got a
pan real in your mouth how those baby
demon spawn well let me um
opening doors like I can find where they
move the files too
why do I need the files you'll find the
ladies telling me yeah but I keep
freaking boxers I don't even know why
because I'm nice but [ __ ] pack bitter
you have good knees hands but I'm taking
it with you anyway married nice
no no no no no no no no no run pack
I'm [ __ ] running what the hell it is
it good for you you are fast good for
you good for you
glad I wasted that wasted more all right
anyone want to drill in the face no
one's looking for an appointment with
dr. Phibbs
I put holes in your face all right here
we go
[ __ ] you boss [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you like
[ __ ] bar
big you got a break in bottles yeah
there's so much stuff in them thank you
all right what's up what's up documents
what's up do what do what do what I dare
you to tell me no no no no no no no no
no no no no
oh you're safe now
uh-huh everything is going to do okay
I'm pretty screwed and that's what I am
is it over now it's over that's a kind
of anticlimactic ending overall extra
accent yeah
35% [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] damage healed
that's how we roll here in pittypat town
drill usage overall score 7,000 my mama
would be proud my mama would be proud
ah that ended a little bit sooner than I
expected but hey what Kenya damn I hope
it was enjoy the last play I think
there's a different ending if you play
it on hardcore I'm not really into
replaying it I don't think there's yeah
I mean I personally probably would have
done it bad and really I'm time to do it
some and I don't think you know started
like all over it but hey I was a pretty
cool mod you know I can't argue with
that I really enjoyed playing it it was
short and sweet I guess it's the best
way to put it I like what is my name
doing there goodbye thank you for your
donation yeah guys that's it Kyle robust
I thought
oh well alright catalog I care anyway I
can finish me good gonna start a new
let's play I don't know maybe softball
already I don't know
that's it as it would again look there's
something don't just stand there alright
let's take it think your lightsaber and
do do your thing Oh